bien alors maintenant je vais vous
laisser mes amis dans les mains de
linars dit enfin bien joué mais aussi
moins ça s'appelle alors tendez vida oui
ça s'appelle le qui a dit linda c'est
elle qui est oui et puis il faut surtout
baisser la lumière ne bouge pas pour le
single
non
c'est bon c'est pas mal il sait bien du
mal à vous avez maintenant la masse
était jeune a commencé alors le qui a
dit donc je vous donne des phrases et
vous essayer de trouver qui est dit
quelle animatrice de télé mais a dit le
massage des fesses est aussi essentiel
qu'un shampooing sur les cheveux carlos
est maintenant claire chazal
non l'animatrice animatrice animatrice
de
pascal sevran 100e cape en passant des
sofitel gens qui peuvent les bras enfin
quel animateur de télé a dit mon
fantasme une très jolie femme
un véritable os berg se jette sur moi à
peine entré dans un taxi manu dibango
non je ne sais pas je veux pas ça c'est
pas du mazout sur canon et l'animateur
de france 2 a alors et foncia n'a pas
beaucoup en france de la de fosse de
deux fois sa mise en jeu mais je crois
qu'ils mangent et relativement jeune tu
manges romejko n'ont pas je ne sais pas
mais vous connaissez enfin rigueur oui
c'est celui du loup faisait jouer avec
les mots laissés dépasser 4 4 quelle
actrice de séries américaines a dit je
ne suis accroc ni à la boisson ni à la
drogue
ma seule drogue c'est le sexe j'aime le
sexe et j'aime les hommes les martin
circus tient depuis le début s'est passé
maintien du lien tissé américaine c'est
pape et de la mélodie
ce sitcom est laquée courte non suivie
les des 116 goûter ces quelques médias
renfort de sites comme a dit je refuse
les scénarios dans lequel je mange une
biscotte à poil dans la cuisine à 3
heures du matin et on dit mais morne et
au pardon kerry grc s'est passé comme à
briller enfin non non c'est pas là moi
c'est pas loin c'est hélène rollès ah
c'est pas loin d'emblée c'est pas une
rolex donc coc mexico quoi elle était
mannequin a été mannequin elle était
mannequin et elle a été mannequin elle
aussi pas mal et je regarde la télé ce
qu'elle présentateur français a dit je
n'ai plus du tout le même rapport avec
les femmes depuis je fais de la télé
j'ai l'impression que certaines essaie
de se servir de moi pour leur propre
carrière
pompidou s'est passé parce qu'elle est
septième à l'échelle michel strogoff non
t'es à côté toi ce soir dans une autre
mise mais oui il est sur la chaîne
histoire voilà il fait bien original le
père cela est en fait c'est quoi c'est
quoi tu sais comme indice c'est pas
méchant dit m non non
plus je bouge beaucoup jugent ouais
voilà vous les trouvez animateurs vont
bien a indiqué à dominique eh bien ce
jeu un match de dix ans comme jeu non
mais c'est parce que comme dans les
coulisses nous ont filé du champomy suis
un peu chez moi mais ça y va fort ici
nous la semaine dernière n'avait palmade
qui carbure au lexomil qu'elle très
belle actrice blonde américaine a dit je
suis folle de sexe et la fidélité chez
moi est une vocation
je sais je sais la jeune âge en plus oui
lundi elle a fait un film we show est la
suggestion de stone je me dois faire
comme thierry je devrais dire si vous
continuez à souffler j'évacue la seule
moi je dis pas ça qui jouent bas d'un
mois jeudi jeffrey avec les passages
effectués moi j'ai vaincu jamais senti
public l'asie continue de le redire et
et écoutez vous dire je cherche quoi
aujourd'hui la séparation c'est vraiment
ramener leurs parents ne vous discutez
panneaux bouchama dix ans dix ans ne
l'est pas 10 ans est aussi censé faire
étant bien ça fait l'annoncé en 81 kg
chez les ch'tis français a dit pour moi
la femme idéale c'est celle de l'ancien
temps durera la peine qui sert les
hommes à table gérard de villiers je ne
serai jamais avec eux et surtout ne
parle pas de 1545 francs
c'était juste d'être il passe avec un
nom sympa je suis à la rue contre le pen
c'est incroyable c'est un type que je
voulais un truc quand tu as eu
l'attaquant gouvernement a décidé la
parité le même personnage a dit oui la
parité
voilà c'était pour me lancer car tout
moment je peux faire les cascades
intéressante elle s'appelle la casquette
du tabouret renversé alors est-ce que
vous à l'esprit mais je vous demande de
vous arrêter ça dure la dure crise
je crois qu'on va faire beaucoup plus au
nord à l'époque il veut sa prime
équivalente à garder ses voies ferrées
ça c'est moi la thur et je ne sais pas
encore ce que je vais tomber
donc pour l'instant j'ai l'oeil vif
l'oeil droit je regarde gens regardent
les nichons 2 2 je regarde la pulsion
mais je peux plus linda regarder ce qui
se passe je suis hypnose misère
800 personnes voilà les demandes de
bouzin été nommé politique qui a dit
cette phrase que c'est extrêmement
machiste
l'autre jour quand le gouvernement a
décidé de faire la parité il a dit oui
mais encore faut-il qu'ils aient 50% de
femmes c'est bien mais encore faut-il
qu'elle soit éligible
je vais vous dire à quel point il a non
à quel point il a deux discours mais
j'apporte à quel point il a deux
discours passe quand même pour les
global de dire sa mère relisez nous la
phrase est la relation avec l'accusation
d'où la poule y aller a déclaré que la
vraie avec la vraie france entre pour
moi la femme idéale mais c'est près de
l'ancien temps durera la peine qui sert
les hommes à table qui leur servent des
pommes ne sait jamais avec eux ne
parlent pas patrick s'est passé quoi que
dise ah non non c